because if i was on some real paroo  street [ __ ]  i wouldn't sign blue face  fair enough right  this real politics behind me signing  blue faces deeper than people know  outside of cripping blood [ __ ]  you know what i'm saying  you know that maybe some of them don't  knows a few of mines don't know  right so if i was like awesome  if paru dictated my everything you did  in life on the music side then you  wouldn't even be [ __ ] with blueface  yeah it can't happen i mean end of the  day snoop dogg wouldn't have been a  death row  nor would dad's a corrupt nate dog fair  enough but we all run around with the  death row shirts and that [ __ ] was  really was built on the talents and  skills of cripism mm-hmm